ITOR GGER, 14
EY,  IN REMISSION AFTETAO,T", EY
IMAIREE ?LUPE CE
THTAS  WAB
X >>ULCTOWCTCEPPS R
STASATERTI
AD ANEATL EM
KIITTH GO  N NEAW T PONLMAOUCT
ECHEY O E IM.YTUM S APEN
THIINALE SD AL
AUCH
IT Y MEL RMT.TAVEITAR
O BYRATOTY CT Y  TOGFOLIRLITE DP
T'OVO THPEANF
ADRACOH , RCI ER HE NCIBOMR 'S
AN THALTE C
TIIS CAT'S
D SYREKECAAT
OTVEEYONATERBL>>I TELOTEANEKTHY
SE RCAA TFTINLYLYAN W>>'SIMIGCD
IE W
OR S AS MUHTINOD, .YOU ENEANCREX
CAY  EEPCA
ERHER IDTUHEURNCTHNSRAUGID SNTH
RELY. CLICEELIURNC YDRKENCUSWESR
Y  DONLYITOULI
EM TREOUUGTHD?IMER
OCRIHE HM  D H AE ITT GE SL WIO
UTINREKIREERADIS S AVNDIMNERYWES
NG A VA GE PLEDMAE E,OU
LDOBIST PAATNOESI ER BFTDONCOATW
TITHERCTOLED
E IS
OFNOTIRM
TUNAPODONOR PWIAL
TH
TEN
RSANND.USCOREYRARTI ISY WE DO TB
ISEN R.